[Music]
if you've heard the opening theme of the
loud house you know that song can get
stuck in your head all day but did you
know there are some cool things we found
hidden in the intro of the show watch
until the end to find out what book
Lincoln is trying to read if you're new
to the things channel be sure to hit
that notification valve to be the first
to see our latest videos and click the
thumbs up button if you liked this video
now here are ten things you never
noticed in the loud house intro Lily
finger painting the wall lily is the
youngest of the loud siblings but that
doesn't mean she is any less messy on
the contrary she is known as the
stinkiest loud in the house those dirty
diapers are even sung about in the
opening theme song but Lily makes an
impact early on in the song - in the
extended version of the loud house
opening theme song Lincoln runs down the
hallway dodging all of his sisters the
loud sisters are all engaged in
activities that fit their personalities
the first sister we encounter in the
hallway is little baby lily loud we
don't have to see her face to see that
she is up to no good
it looks like lily is becoming just like
her older siblings she may not be
ducking dodging pushing or shoving to
show her love yet but she is still
making her mark it's hilarious that we
can't even see her face it's just the
back of her head and her diaper which
are covered in finger paints Lily is
creating a masterpiece on the hallway
wall she is so busy with her wall art
she doesn't even notice Lincoln running
by Lincoln runs by so fast it's hard to
make out the painting still nice use of
color Lily is that a square yolk Lincoln
seems like a helpful dude he just wants
a little peace and quiet and who can
blame him he is surrounded by sisters
any person who has even had one annoying
sister can tell you that one is enough
poor Lincoln has ten sisters that's a
whole lot of estrogen in one house it's
a wonder he has survived this long still
it seems Lincoln does his best to take
care of his sisters like in the extended
opening theme song when Lincoln is
handing out breakfast to a line of
sisters but if you look closely you'll
see that Lincoln has a different type of
dish for each sister it looks like
winning is having egg whites Luna likes
her eggs sunny-side up and then we get
to LuAnn
we all know that LuAnn is a total
jokester of course she would have some
sort of wacky and conventional breakfast
but did you guys notice that somehow
Lincoln puts an egg on her plate that
has a square shape to yolk how did he
pull that one off
Lincoln looks pretty proud of himself
for that one and LuAnn looks really
excited
apparently Lincoln is the kind of chef
who can defy the laws of physics driving
up the wall ah sweet pretty little Lola
she has been described as bratty spoiled
sassy arrogant conceived and smart-mouth
but this girl is all princess at heart a
very vain princess with a bit of an
attitude but hey at least she's a gal
who knows what she wants
fans of the loud house are all too
familiar with Lola's little pink
princess Jeep she uses it to get around
the house and inside the house although
she is an excellent driver she's a bit
prone to road rage that is all the more
apparent when you see that she has run
down her sister Lucy at the top of the
hallway stairs in the extended opening
theme song the look of complete rage on
her face makes it obvious that while she
probably floored it up the stairs Hitty
Lucy was not an accident
and speaking of accidents what happened
to the walls how did Lola manage to
drive up the walls and even onto the
ceiling is that an antigravity Jeep and
just exactly how much torque and power
does that little pink Jeep engine have
Lola is not messing around with that
thing and she certainly isn't fooling
anyone with the sweet princess look that
girl is a walking traffic violation what
did the baby do in the pool if you're a
super loud fan you'll probably get the
reference in the extended theme about
the kiddie pool
you know the episode where the loud kids
get kicked out of the community pool for
all of you who need a quick refresher
check it out on a hot summer day the
loud family visits the local community
pool but they roughly get kicked out
Lincoln decides to buy his own little
inflatable pool in the hopes to enjoy a
little paradise for one in his backyard
it's not long before the entire brood is
crammed into Lincoln's pool before he
even has a chance to attempt the first
cannonball he kicks out his siblings and
learns very quickly that it's lonely in
the pool all by himself he goes to the
front yard to see that the kids all
chipped in for a huge pool with a
waterslide Lincoln attempts to
cannonball into that pool and it rips
he invites the
to his pool and that's when a little
fecal incident happens the kids freak
out and jump out of the pool well
everyone except for Lily weirdest
cartwheel we've ever seen we all know
that Luna is the lab family's resident
rock legend while Luna is a pretty happy
wild and compassionate sibling she is
also probably the loudest loud in the
house she loves playing guitar with
giant amps and sweet rocker riffs but
Luna doesn't only play the guitar she
also plays other instruments like the
drum and violin
she's a pretty talented loud kid even if
she does talk in a fake British accent
sometimes piss totally annoys her
siblings anywho with all of Lunas
talents it's hard to imagine she is
capable of even more but the extended
opening theme shows a pretty weird skill
that Luna has it's in the part where the
kids mom and dad are watching them
through the window Lana is sitting on
the fence twirling a lasso above her
head LuAnn is hugging a tree and Luna
well she is doing this totally bizarre
armless cartwheel she's got this big
dopey smile on her face and her hands
down on her sides
Luna stiffly flipped through the yard
onto her head and then back onto her
feet then on her head again as Lisa runs
through the yard the lyrics say gotta
love mom and dad we're not going
completely mad but we think Lunas the
baddie one here cardinal directions on
remotes it's clear that Lincoln needs a
bit of alone time away from miss sisters
in the TV intro to the loud house we see
him navigating through a sea of sisters
to try to get some TV time of his own
Lincoln has to jump over a speeding
motorcycle leap out of the way of Lisa's
latest science experiment slip in for a
tea party with Lola rock out with Luna
slip under a shirt that Lori and linear
fighting over then he is assaulted by
the steaming comments of Lily's diaper
he almost gets a pie in the face from
Louann before he hauls it into the
bathroom to escape but he's not safe in
the bathroom Lana's mixing the scene and
she unleashes a tidal wave from the
bursting pipe which sends winkin
bursting through the wall and down the
stairs after all that anyone would want
to take a break but that's not in the
cards for Lincoln he grabs the TV remote
and eventually ends in the
of a sister pile on the couch but did
you guys notice what was on the remote
when he picked it up it has the cardinal
directions on it you know north south
east west
Lucy will not say cheese Lucy vadas be
quietest and most gloomy of all the loud
kids
she loves dark poetry like that of Edgar
Allen Poe she's a total goth girl with a
habit of popping up and scaring people
from out of nowhere this especially
freaks Lincoln out Lucy is interested in
the supernatural he sometimes wonders if
she is a witch Lucy feels like nobody
listens to her she believes everyone
thinks she is weird so she wears her
frown on her pale face most of the time
picture time is no exception as we see
in the intro of the show there's a part
where we see all of the portraits of the
loud kids on the wall all of the sisters
are smiling except for Lucy that
signatures slight Brown is a big
contrast to the big toothless grins on
Lola and Lana or is it just us or does
she always look like she just had a
bucket of waters flashed over her head
Lucy is not interested in smiling for
the pictures of the wall she is only
interested in poetry and saying the word
psy instead of actually just you know
sign that's right ladies and gentlemen
Lucy will not say T's hidden message
people have played songs backwards to
try and get some sort of hidden meaning
since the 60s it's not a new thing at
all back then rock and roll has a
reputation for being considered the
devil's music
so people used to look for sinister
hidden messages in the songs to prove
their theory for instance Beatles fans
thought there was a hidden message in
the song strawberry fields forever if
the song is played backwards
it sounds like John Lennon the same that
he buried Paul this bans the flames of
rumors that Paul McCartney was deceased
the rumors said that the band was trying
to cover up the loss of Paul's by hiring
a double who looks like Paul to fool the
fans some fans believe there is a hidden
subliminal message in the loud house
intro if you play the song backwards
it's the part where all the kids rush
down the stairs and line up a couple of
bands played this part backwards and
found that it sounds like they are
saying ends me no one is really sure
what that means but has some Vince
totally creeped out they commented that
they think that it's disturbing and
creepy magic potions for Lincoln that
kid can't catch a break in the extended
intro he rhymes from place to place to
get some quiet time to read his comic
book he tries everything he goes to his
bedroom but Lucy is there
he even hides in the trash can but that
doesn't work either what's a guy to do
Lincoln tries to hide in the bathtub to
read alone the poor little dude gets
drenched when Lori turns on the shower
she pulls back the shower curtain to
find a perturbed Lincoln totally soaked
and not looking very happy about it
what's this guy gotta do to get some me
time around here we noticed something a
little odd about the shampoo bottles
above Lincoln's head they don't look
like your ordinary bottles they kind of
look like potion bottles we know Lucy
fancies herself as a witch sometimes
making things or her magic potions or
maybe they are a part of Lisa's science
experiments regardless it's probably
best if Lincoln and Lori should probably
not use whatever is in those bottles
unless they want to wind up with some
weird mutation on top of their heads we
all know what Lisa is capable of with
those experiments muscle fish while
we're on the subject of Lincoln's
reading material here's a fun thing we
noticed in the intro Lincoln is reading
a comic book called muscle fish most
true lighthouse fans know that muscle
fish is one of Lincoln's favorite
characters muscle fish appears in video
games toys and on Lincoln's comic books
but did you know that muscle fish is a
parody character of the comic book
character savage dragon
they are both green and muscular
although with savage dragons super
strength and super healing powers he
also suffers from amnesia you can't
remember anything before waking up in
the burning filled in Chicago mob makes
us wonder if Lincoln sometimes wishes he
had amnesia so he could forget the fact
that he lives at a house full of girls
it makes sense that Lincoln would
idolize a giant green crazy eyed fish
just look at that guy he is pretty
intimidating none of the loud sisters
would stand a chance against that a
weird creature looks like she punched
all of those clouds in the face we
hopefully can get the chance to read
it's favorite comic book eventually
what's your favorite part of the loud
house intro to be miss any unusual
things in the opening
Dean let us know in the comments and
that was ten things you never noticed in
the loud house intro thanks for watching
the things see you next time
[Music]